foreign
my parents what seemed to me like have
checked out of my sister's life she is
leaving her school you know smoking has
been hanging out with the wrong crowd I
suggested to them to let her come live
with me and my family and I want to make
sure I'm doing the right thing
[Music]
hey everybody this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
sure we talk about mental health about
families about parenting about
whatever's going on in your life and in
your world
what's going on in your schools and your
kids schools
um
I'm just gonna the one the one promise I
make on the show not that I'm going to
be right all the time because I'm not
um
the promise I make on this show is I'm
always gonna tell the truth and
um this is a hard show today I'm I'm
here in Nashville Tennessee and I
realize that you're getting this this
podcast release uh this YouTube release
uh three weeks after the fact
um but I'm sitting here in my city
and we're hurting
um this is the day after
um the senseless shooting at
Covenant School here in town
and the smoke is clearing and people are
asking hard questions and there's
investigations and all this stuff
um I was up this morning doing early
media all the the stuff that happens
when hard things happen
um
and
it's something that's really important
to me in these moments is
to not let
um
not let my answers and not let my desire
to be right and not let my desire to
point fingers take over the fact that
there are
countless families and people who are
forever changed
and forever heartbroken and I know that
I I always start this show with laughter
and we're loud and we're talking about
it
I would not be being honest and
um if I if I started the show this way
and so what I want to do is I want to
take a moment and do what I what I
like to I don't like to do it but but I
do every time there's a tragedy like
this and
take a moment and honor the
people who lost their life here
um three young young kids
and three adults
um
from a leader to a janitor I mean
um so if you will honor these families
with uh a moment of silence
while I read their names
these are the young ones who lost their
lives
yesterday in the senseless shooting
Evelyn Dyke house
age nine
Haley Scruggs age nine
little William Kenny age nine
Cynthia Peak 61.
Catherine Koontz 60.
Mike Hill 61.
there's also countless police officers
who showed up and had to see things and
experience things that no one should
ever see or experience and there's
countless
young kids who
were run out through the parking lot
there's countless adults who are
answering questions across this country
and across the world and across the city
they don't have answers and so here's
what I'll tell you
um often these are moments when pundits
come out and start running their mouths
and telling you here's what I think
here's what I think I'm not going to do
that I'm gonna tell you what I did
and I got this call that this had
happened the first thing I did is reach
out to my wife to make sure my kids were
okay
and it's easy to feel guilty about that
no parents should feel guilty about
wanting to reach out and put their hands
on their kids and put their eyes on
their kids
and at the same time be devastated and
heartbroken for the moms and dads whose
lives are
effectively as they knew him over and
now there's Ash and there was going to
be
years of
what ifs and what abouts and healing and
heartbreak and all the stuff that goes
with nonsense like this
but I also told my kids I'm real real
sad
devastated heartbroken my son who's 12
almost 13 saw his dad almost unable to
breathe last night when I was hugging
him
and I walked through what I knew my son
was gonna hear today at school and what
I thought he should do which is mostly
be quiet and listen and also talk to him
about I know your teachers are going to
go over the active shooter drill
response and here's what I think um you
should do there
and that's not a conversation everyone
had with a 13 year old I don't like
having those conversations with adults
but that's my world and that's my
reality that's all of our world in
reality right now
well my seven-year-old daughter I held a
real real tight and I told her some
really scary things happen I didn't go
into great detail
she hadn't heard anything
and um
I'll be a little more sensitive with
what she hears and what she knows and do
more question answering than
um uh then
telling her what I think because she's
seven she's young
so trying to pretend that you're strong
and tough for your kids is not the
moment here it's not the thing to do in
this moment the the thing to do in this
moment is to let your kids know that you
can't breathe and in that you're sick
and that this world's a messy messy
ridiculous sick place
and then I'm gonna let my kids see me do
the next right thing
so this morning I woke up really early
and I skipped most of my workout and
uh I even skipped my gratitude time and
I took my son out to breakfast
and I showed him the next right thing
and we treated the waitress really well
and we tipped her really well and we
talked and I was extra intentional about
my touch I was extra intentional about
making sure he looked me in the eyes
when I told him I love you when he left
to get up for school today
and um
I'm gonna continue to lean in that way
and that doesn't
um have anything to do with what I'm
going to do as a citizen of the city and
a citizen of this country those are
separate conversations and those are
things that will
um I Will Do privately
in the days and weeks and months and
years to come
but right now everybody's hurting and
I'm gonna sit in that hurt I'm not gonna
run from it and I'm not gonna deny it
I'm not gonna lie about it I'm gonna sit
in it
and I hope for a minute you'll join me
and again I know this is three weeks
later when you're getting this and I
know many of you want this thing to just
move on and to and to um shut the door
and be onto the next Shiny Bright thing
that's not how grief works
grief demands a witness and grief
demands that we sit together and hold
one another
and Evelyn and Haley and will and
Cynthia and Kathy and Mike
[Music]
will be missed until the end of time
thanks for joining us
um
we'll take some calls we'll be right
right back on the Dr John Dillon show
hey deloney here folks getting out of
debt and getting good sleep have
something in common intentionality when
you're working your way out of debt you
have to be purposeful you got to build
your emergency fund pay off your debt
smallest to largest and stick with it
all that stuff and when you're ready to
invest in good sleep you have to have a
plan too you got to get that early
morning sunlight you gotta exercise you
gotta cut out all this caffeine and you
gotta limit screen time and you have to
budget for a premium quality mattress
because it makes an enormous difference
and that's why I recommend dream Cloud
mattresses and for my friends on a
budget I have incredible news right now
dream cloud is offering my listeners 25
off their order plus 50 in additional
savings and why not 599 more dollars in
accessories with promo code John deloney
that's pillows luxury sheets and a
mattress protector and dream Cloud gives
you a one-year in-home trial so you can
make sure it's the right fit so it's
time to invest in good sleep have a
budget meeting with your spouse make a
plan and then go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney to get your
new mattress today that's
dreamcloudsleep.com and use code John
deloney
all right we're back let's go out to uh
Laura in Dallas Texas hey Laura what's
up
hey Dr John deloney how are you I'm all
right how are you
good um I wanted to say
um first of all I'm very sorry about
what the families in Tennessee are going
through my family and I have been
definitely praying for you guys but I'm
very thankful for your team and your
family and yourself for a show like this
because I think it's a drop in the
bucket to help us with how you said like
this world it's not the easiest so I
really appreciate everything y'all do
thank you so so much I I appreciate your
your
thinking about us and um thanks for your
call thanks for your call uh what's
going on in your world
have a three and a five-year-old both
boys my husband is a teacher um I have a
15 year old sister same parents
um my parents
um I think just got to the point where
they are doing their best but almost
have what seemed to me like have checked
out as my sister's life it the situation
has gotten out of control where she is
leaving her school
um you know smoking has been hanging out
with the wrong crowd and my sister has a
great heart so I
um I've been trying to help my parents
in ways uh with suggestions but it's
almost like they just
don't want to upset my sister they're a
little bit scared and I suggested to
them to let her come live with me and my
family and I want to make sure I'm doing
the right thing there my parents are
planning to leave the city that they're
in to move to uh more of
um
outside where like kind of like a farm
just to give my sister kind of a better
opportunities and so I offer to for her
to come live with us for a while
um and I want to make sure you know I've
always lived by like a United Family as
a strong family so I want to make sure
that I'm not causing her any harm but I
do stay home I'm going to be
homeschooling the plan is to homeschool
my sister and put her in activities to
keep her busy but like I said I'm trying
my best
to not bring her harm to you know taking
away you know I don't want to take her
away from my parents at the end of the
day because that's you know those are
her parents and
um
but I do I am kind of desperate at this
point because I see how my sister's
going and I don't see the urgency in my
parents she's leaving school that opens
up the door for her to get trafficked
um just a whole bunch of things getting
and so yeah I'm just really nervous and
want to make sure I'm doing the right
thing for her and just wanted to see if
you had any advice or your opinion on it
yeah thanks for thanks for your heart
for loving your sister
um
have you talked to her
yes I have you'll just sat down and had
just a a woman-to-woman talk
yes we have we've had a bunch of talks
and they have always been amazing
um she knows that I am not the sister to
hide lies for from my parents either if
they put her in a dangerous situation
um but she's very very open with me she
knows that she can't make decisions on
her own which my parents think a lot of
the times it's her responsibility she's
making the decision she's the one who's
lying but I always tell her look if
they're putting you in a situation that
a 15 year old like cannot decide on
herself it's not all your fault because
I mean I'm not going to give her a car
without giving her lessons how to drive
so I feel like that's kind of the
situation that she's in with
my parents so
um she you know tells me yeah that's
completely right I need someone to like
make decisions for me so I had told her
I said I think it's the good ideas maybe
you can come live with me a little while
and
um she also agreed and then you know she
backtracked she's like well maybe not
all summer and so I was like you know I
think it'll be healthy for you to come
live with me and have some
responsibility at my house and
um I I have the freedom to take her to
to horseback riding lessons like piano
lessons anything that keeps her busy as
well so I thought that would be good so
I
I think it I think it's a mix of both
um I think I think you're you're on the
right track with
um adults have to provide models and
pictures of what healthy relationships
look like they have to provide structure
and boundaries and when kids don't get
structure and Boundary boundaries they
go racing to see where the boundaries
end and when a kid finds no fences and
no boundaries and
um older parents who've just checked out
or younger Prince who've just checked
out and they will find boundaries
they're usually found with other kids
and that's when you're getting a huge
mess and so
um my pushback for you is this I want
you to recognize the gravity of what's
Happening Here and it may 100 be worth
it for you okay and I'm not going to
tell you right or wrong you should or
shouldn't do it but essentially what
you're doing as a 28 year old is you're
coming in and looking at your mom and
dad and saying y'all are failing at this
and the cat the cost of your failure is
the loss of my sister
I Won't Stand By and Watch that happen
um
that's different than hey why don't you
just come spin this the summer with big
sister and here's why if she's coming to
live with you and you have what I would
call ulterior
ulterior motives I'm going to keep her
real busy I'm gonna get her in
activities you basically are inserting
yourself as
I'm gonna do a better job of parenting
her than her actual mom and dad do if
that's the thought behind it all you
gotta say those things out loud because
your sister's not stupid
correct and what you don't want to have
is her show up in two weeks in feel like
there's a bait and switch
okay oh you just brought me here because
you're gonna make me fill in the blank
you're gonna give me a bunch of chores
and a bunch of I'm out of here this
sucks I thought I was just coming to
hang out with big sister because Mom and
Dad are dumb
see what I'm saying
right so it will be hey I want you to
come here I see value in you I want my
little ones to be around their um aunt
and you've got to get some structure in
your life I love you and I care about
you I'm a grown woman just 13 years down
the road from you and I see where you're
headed and I love you enough if you're
ready for a a fun summer and a summer of
accountability and change
um I love to open my house up to you you
see how one's different and she might
look at you and say absolutely not I'm
not doing that right
um and and that brings sorry go ahead no
you go ahead go ahead that brings me
Comfort because that's that's exactly
how I feel
um I don't want to be naive and think oh
I know better than my parents because
I've never had this it's easier said
than done and my parents are doing their
best regardless
um but it's true I I do want to just be
big sister and I have you know as humbly
as possible I have told my parents I
cannot stand and watch this any longer
because I have like my hands tied behind
my back with any sort of suggestion
um what do they say to you
they tell me thank you and that they
will consider you know what I say and
that they know that I love her very much
but that is easier said than done
um but it's I but I also have heard my
dad say we don't know what to do anymore
or he'll say like what do I do in this
case but it's a rhetorical question and
in my head I'm like well take the phone
away from her she shouldn't have social
media but obviously I want to respect my
my dad as well so I TR like it's very
very difficult for me to not have a
judgment towards them because this is my
one and only sister and I love her
so it's very very much
I go all in either way
okay meaning if you are
like I would sit down with my dad if I'm
you and say you have communicated
several times you don't know what to do
you've communicated several times that
that little sister's gone crazy and
she's doing this and this and we just
don't know what's next
I would like her to come live with me
for the summer and I am going to walk
her through some things that I think
would provide some accountability and if
you're open to it after being with her
for the summer I would love to feel you
and Mom in on here's some things I think
that would be helpful I've walked this
world it's just new Everything's changed
and I don't as some dads and moms would
lose their freaking mind if their kids
said that to them
or some moms and dads May exhale and say
thank God this world just went bananas
and I don't know what to do
right right and they're a little bit of
both okay okay and I don't I don't blame
them because obviously I'm sure it's a
little hit in the ego sometimes and I
don't know best but I do try to like get
the tools that for my own kids whenever
they grow up so I just use the
suggestions from like what I'm learning
sure
I want to have as clear a picture as
possible about what happens not if but
when younger sister violates curfew when
younger sister is smoking on the back
porch or she has figured out a way to
get a hold of a phone and she whatever
your rules are going to be you and your
husband have to be lockstep and your
parents lockstep on here's what will
happen are you in a position to hold her
accountable for things and I would
suggest when she shows up
we you take her out you've heard me say
this a million times on the show
with a with a sort of helper walk
through here's what a value statement
looks like here's what a value like who
are we who are we going to be
and you can let her know here are some
values I've made in my life and this may
be a really extraordinary time for her
for you to tell her about some
stupid guy you were with in college or
some things you said yes to that you
would like write let her know a peek
behind the curtain that she may not know
about big sister and it gives you some
um it will allow her to go oh she does
know what she's talking about right
yeah I have something in the books like
that there you go so it's not going to
be uh it's not silicious and it's not
like oh yeah look what I did too it's
not like that because I've also been
around a little bit older folks who try
to bro down
you know what I mean like use all the
cool words I've been guilty of this
before especially when I was younger of
trying to like appear cool like yeah I
know what's up and I know how to get a
hold of whatever that's not it it's hey
I've been here and here's what you don't
understand about what's coming
here's what he's got go ahead
my kids took my cool card away a long
time ago
my daughter repeatedly just tears it up
and uh hands it back to me Oh I thought
I had a few more years but no no no no
it was long gone but I he the The Meta
word I'm using here is Clarity very very
clear about what we're taking on okay
and if this is just summer camp at Aunt
Laura's I mean it says to Laura's house
let it be summer campus sister Laura's
house and we're going to try to
influence positivity if this is no I'm
taking over Mom and Dad for three months
then let make sure everybody's in the
know on that
okay and be real clear with your husband
here's when she gets shipped out of here
got it here's when she goes back home
here's and let her know here's what we
can't have in this house you cannot
smoke if you're gonna be in this house
this house is social media free that
means you're gonna have to be off it too
right yep and I work yeah yeah that's
true I am ready for that though awesome
and and I think and maybe even you frame
it as I'm making some Life Changes too
like I'm on social media too much I'm
off it for the summer I'm gonna look at
it once a night or whatever you can do
that in your bedroom when when she's
gone to bed or whatever the thing is
right but
um I think that the big thing here is
this is going to be harder than you
think and so let's be very very clear as
it as it happens
all right sure thing I think okay
what does a a punishment look like for
oh I know that it has to go with the you
know with what she broke but for example
I don't I'm not going to take her phone
away or her or her TV time because she
can't have that in myself or in my house
we watch movies as a family we took that
advice that y'all y'all doing y'all's
house and we we do that too so I'm
um
I'm I'm not really sure everything's
about choices but so okay everything
will be framed around choices which is
which is why your Clarity up front is so
important here's what I mean by that
if you choose to do X you're choosing to
step away from us
got it right
um I'm not don't weaponize your
relationship don't weaponize her
relationship with her nephews don't
don't weaponize her relationship with
her uncle
um because then it looks like you are
withholding love because she didn't
perform up to your standards
instead look at her and say we're
inviting you in and we're we're adding
another leg to this table and so this
house is going to function best when
you're here
okay when you're a part of it
um I want you to have a um an hour in
the morning with the boys I'll pay you
and uh I'm gonna hire you for some of
this stuff this summer
um so you can have the experience of
having a job too right
um and maybe it's maybe it's sister
Laura's boot camp this summer whatever
you however you want to frame it but
frame it in a positive yet this is not
going to be easy right and I think kids
today are craving challenges
they're desperate for adults to look at
them and say whoa whoa you can do so
much more right it's it's just providing
like you said the scaffolding to that so
the whole thing didn't fall over when
they make mistakes but it's going to be
her if you if you if you you can't this
is a house where we don't curse in front
of the kids
if you curse in front of the kids you're
choosing to not be in the room with
those kids please don't make that choice
this house works so much better when
you're here and then she does it which
she will
then you have to hold that line because
your mom and dad don't hold that line
and she's gonna see if you're telling
the truth or not yes right right so
everything is about choices she's making
if she chooses to go home because she
finds some dude to give her alcohol she
chooses to go home because she finds
somebody to buy her smokes and what like
that's a choice she makes
and it's let her know this breaks my
heart because I wanted you here I want
you here and you're choosing to leave
perfect that makes complete
stuff I'm very excited
let me know how it goes
love to call me anytime throughout the
summer not if but when it gets sideways
in in bananas
um but I think
as much honesty and openness as possible
and keep a tiny little
um space in your heart for this thing
whole thing to go south
yes sister to say I hate you you're dumb
remember she's a child right yep yep and
your parents to say how dare you I I
wiped your butt I watched your mom give
birth to you expect all that crap too
correct totally fine with me I don't
even care so okay as yeah I do as you
know I'm gonna be my very best and do it
as loving as possible and I'm not going
to blame anyone for how they react not
by business how someone else reacts but
I am going to do my best I love that uh
clear as kind clear as kind clear as
kind and Laura thank you for loving her
and thank you for loving your parents
and
um
no parent no parent wants their kids to
give them advice
it's the brave parents it I'll just be
honest my mom called me this morning and
said hey I'm working through an issue
what do you think there's there's
something really profound when a parent
goes oh great one of my kids is an
expert in this thing or they know this
thing I'll call them that's awesome many
parents don't have the courage or the
strength to get there
um moms and ads if you're over your head
and you've got a great child like Laura
Reach Out reach out and say hey can you
help
um we're at our Wit's End here and we
need we need some support
um but for those of you you kids who are
just like Mom and Dad are making stupid
decisions sometimes they have more
wisdom than you sometimes it's it's a
different conversation and sometimes you
just gotta be prepared for them to say I
would rather take I would rather take
wisdom from uh raccoons backside
raccoon's butthole and from from you I I
don't know where raccoon's butthole came
from I just screwed up this whole call
sorry guys but Laura you know what you
know I'm talking about I'm gonna end the
call here we'll be right back on the Dr
John DeLuca show
hey good folks John deloney here
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right we're back um hey during the
break we gave uh Laura the last caller
questions for humans cards that she
could use
um
when her teen sister shows up for summer
boot camp summer get right with Sister
Laura Camp right all right let's go out
to Andrew in Tulsa Oklahoma what's up
Andrew
there you go it's uh for a long time
listener first time caller and I'm glad
to be on very cool man thanks for
calling brother what's up
so uh I'm 19. I'm in college and I grew
up homeschooled so I wasn't allowed to
date until the age of 18. last summer I
went to summer camp I was one of my
friends and met a girl and we hit it off
pretty well she was in a relationship at
the time no I didn't
so so I didn't you know I didn't push
anything we were just friends and then a
couple weeks later she wasn't sitting
out of the Tulsa so we didn't get to see
each other very often
a couple weeks later her boyfriend broke
up with her because he said that's what
God wanted for them and so I kind of got
soft rebounded on that um she kind of
attached on to me and then I thought
this was the beginning of a relationship
and then she just kept kind of being
I don't think she meant any harm by it
but she kept being a little more
lovey-dovey than I was used to from a
girl
she said it's just because she's
Southern and that's how she rolls and
then wait wait wait wait what does
lovey-dovey mean like saying I love you
every night and saying you're handsome
and saying she want to be my roommate
when we got out of college and stuff
like that
okay
but I mean
having never gone any farther than the
talking phase with anybody before that
was a lot more than I was used to and I
was excited about it of course hey hold
on let's stop right there it feels good
when somebody tells you that you're good
looking
yeah
it feels good when someone says like I I
see a future with you
yeah that's feels awesome man so don't
don't you're not weird that's incredible
feels good it might be it might be a
wrong person it might be dumb but it's
not yeah your feelings are valid man
right right those words definitely have
positive impact and I appreciate that
but
I don't know if she fully meant them the
way she said them um so there's a sheep
hold on hold on hold on hold on if you
can learn what I'm about to say at the
age of 19 I'm gonna change your life
forever okay
there's a psychological construct called
the fundamental attribution error okay
and here's what that means fundamental
attribution error I'm gonna I'm gonna
way oversimplify it but essentially it's
I'm getting inside somebody else's head
and deciding why they did what they did
and said what they said
and what I want to tell you is that is a
complete and utter waste of your entire
life because you'll never know we do it
with politicians he just did that
politicians he just did that because of
this or we do it with our parents
they're just trying to our coaches and
here's the deal we have no idea we have
no idea right and so it's a waste of
time I'm gonna judge somebody on what
they said I'm gonna judge somebody on
what they do and I'm going to judge
myself on both my feelings and the next
right move right and so I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna leave things at face
value if people don't tell me the truth
then I'm gonna respond to that I'm not
gonna get in their head and try to
figure out why are they lying it's just
an exhausting way to live
right don't attribute to malice what you
contribute to ignorance or don't
attribute anything ever
don't attribute anything that also works
too yeah total I mean the number of
times dude I've walked home and I've
been married for I've been married
longer than you've been alive or that
I've walked into my house and there's
shoes laying around or there's something
there and I just instantly create a
story as to why those are there right I
have no idea what my wife's been through
during the day none and by the way
they're my stupid shoes she also created
a story about why I left my crap out
right so it's just it's it's
our whole culture is based on making up
false stories and shoving them into
other people's minds and then blaming
them for them and then judging them for
them and then going to war on social
media or in the news forum absolute
Insanity absolute waste of time
okay that helped
um anyway so she was I found out she was
hanging out with other guys apparently
for something she does a lot she hangs
out one of those other guys and then
starts complaining when they get like
the wrong vibes from her because she's
too
emotionally attaching and stuff
um so we've been I got soft friend zoned
by her probably around like Christmas
time and then the last time we hung out
um I didn't really feel a connection
anymore
okay so I've been pulling back a little
bit and it feels a lot I feel like
looking back now I see how I was
not making the best decisions at the
time and reading too much into motives
and stuff hold on don't do that to
yourself
this is your first go round
yeah you're just you're just learning
yeah and somebody told you they loved
you something they told you that you
were real handsome somebody said hey I
see myself with you in the future it
felt awesome
and then you realized oh she told a
whole bunch of other people that too
yeah here's the here's the word you're
trying to intellectualize this as a like
as a first go-around
I want you just to sit in the the grief
of it all
she didn't tell you the truth man that
hurts
yeah
she kind of LED you on that hurts
to prevent repeating that so I move
faster we don't talk much anymore
um she's with another guy and they seem
to be happy and happy for them I have
forgiven her to the extent that I can
right now there's still a little scar
going on but it's given me trust issues
yeah of course like yeah like when
someone says they're like so this girl
I'm interested right now uh met her a
week ago we've been friends on social
media for a couple months
I I don't know like I don't want to read
anything into what she's doing now
because of what happened don't read
anything into anybody ever right exactly
exactly ask questions and get
information right yeah hey
get to know people you're not
downloading you're not downloading
software
right you're interacting with people and
here's another thing you can have
um
you can have great
super fun relationships with people
that aren't romantic yeah and when you
meet somebody who makes you laugh you
meet somebody that you think is pretty
you meet somebody that as brilliant is a
good thinker
um
like
you don't have to instantly start
putting them in a spreadsheet and trying
to classify what what what column they
go in yeah they're just a great person
that you just met this is awesome Yep
and then you hang on to your values
whatever your values are
I only hold hands and kiss and go on
dates with people that I am pursuing a
long-term romantic relationship if
that's the value you want to set for
yourself knock your lights out or I want
to date a whole bunch of people and
experience a whole bunch of people and
have all kinds of Adventures and great
hang on to those values that's separate
and apart from man I really like
spending time with her she's awesome
she's hilarious she's fun
yep
um and that doesn't mean that I have to
like is she romantic and what she's
trying to say I don't know how she's
trying to say it you start to read voice
tone into text messages and instagramers
like DMS right like okay
a little bit you do it all the time
Andrew all the time every day yeah every
day so
um here's what I want you to do I want
you to imagine on the top of your head
and I'm being I'm I'm gonna sound like
I'm making a joke I'm not being totally
serious okay every time you start
finding yourself okay what is it what
does this mean what is she saying
I want you to imagine there's a pressure
release valve on top of your head like a
like a like a like a hose faucet that
goes on the side of your house and I
want you to reach your hand up do this
in private otherwise someone's gonna
institutionalize you do it private and I
want you just to pretend that you're
turning it and make the noise
let the pressure off
if you don't feel like responding that
day don't respond anytime you think I
have to respond to this person I have to
go do this thing
that's what I want you to challenge
because you're just creating pressure
where pressure does not exist if you
feel like you want to cool and
um I dated people I dated a few people
seriously before I got married I'm
somebody that likes to talk all the time
too much
yeah and then I was dating somebody who
didn't like talking and so I started not
talking trying to preserve this thing
right
then I realized this is never gonna work
because I'm somebody who talks a lot
my wife doesn't love it but she puts up
with it because she loves me you see
what I'm saying right yeah yeah that
makes sense don't lose in your newfound
like I am dating now I am out in the
world I am meeting people I'm don't
don't over professionalize it
practice being with other people
practice experiencing here's who I want
to be in this moment and if this person
doesn't like who I am in this moment if
I'm being a jerk I need to learn
something if I talk too much and I'm
kind of annoying I need to learn some
things
but if this person is making me feel
different than I want to feel or this
person is I I want to do things
so that they think I'm a certain way or
they see me in a certain light I'm
telling you there's an expiration date
on that that eventually Runs Out
because eventually the real you
it has to breathe imagine that person
can rightfully go hey you've not been
telling me the truth either that's not
who you are you're a funny silly guy or
you're a very serious guy are you
somebody who meets somebody and wants to
get serious really fast great there will
be somebody out there for you may not be
this person somebody will meet you and
want to get serious real quick too
awesome lock your lights up
don't compromise your values and don't
overthink this pressure valve on top of
your head just turn it
here dude you're in the right place
injury in the right place keep this keep
this in mind practice here's practicing
you're learning new skills my brother
thanks for the call we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems
but most of us way undervalue real
genuine relationships our friendships
our marriages we don't know what we're
doing and instead of diving into the
mess we accept shallowness and
distraction and we wallpaper over our
loneliness so let me say this boldly you
cannot be well alone you've got to get
connected to real life people and have
deep powerful relationships I'm talking
about relationships where you can be
honest where you can open up where you
can share hard things and you each know
that you'll still show up for each other
and in my new book own your past change
your future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
here at John deloney.com
all right let's go out to Emily in Salt
Lake City hey Emily what's happening
hello Dr John how are you we're figuring
it out today it's a tough one here in
town but we are figuring it out how are
you guys well yes
um you know we're doing okay out here a
lot of snow
don't even know what that means I don't
even know that
um how can I help what's up
um so
um you know honestly
um right now I am just
feeling very
overwhelmed
um I'm exhausted I'm exhausted
physically emotionally spiritually any
any way you can think
um what's going on
a lot going on in my life right now but
um I'll kind of share my question and
then I I ask you to please share this
conversation because we don't have three
hours but okay
um but my question is
um how do I tell my children who are
14 13 and 7. the truth about their
father who they love dearly
um I after I've disguised everything as
much as I possibly could up to this
point
and honestly this is
um Coming forth now as an effort to
protect them
and to prepare them for the person Emily
get to it
you were talking in circles after
circles after circles
what did their dad do
um
well the
um and child sexual abuse
no
actually these I'm sorry hey hold on I'm
I'm sorry
is he coming up on parole
um yes his first parole hearing will be
this summer will he get it
I I honestly
do not know
to trust this system to
consider me in any of the decisions
um though he did he did get sentenced to
prison but
I don't know I I honestly don't know I I
am preparing my or I'm having to prepare
myself
um for him getting out I I don't see him
how are how are you preparing yourself
for that because right now it sounds
like you're holding your breath
right now I right now I'm really not
um right now I am more concerned about
just
being able to protect my kids from what
they don't know you used a word
that I want you to be very very careful
of
you use the word disguised
yes and
that's really close to not telling them
the truth
and I know you're doing it to protect
them to keep them from the hell that you
went through
but in the process of of helping them
and keeping them safe I don't want you
to burn the last relational thing
they're gonna have which is trust in
their mom
okay
no I understand that and that's where
finding a balance is I don't know how
I've
from the time they were born I've you
know I have never involved them in
the arguments or the tension or the you
know anything going on in the home I
tried to they listen Emily they know
fairy tale for them they know
they don't know the specifics
they don't know the details but they
know
I promise you they know
I'm gonna paint you a bleak picture
about the the path this could go on
and then I'm gonna give you some hope
okay
okay here's the Bleak picture
they know they have felt this tension
for years
they've seen Mom disappear
they've seen mom come up with stories
about the
uh why is Dad not here tonight what does
that scrape from I mean what happened to
your
to your eye mommy like they've been
asking these questions for years they
know
but when they don't have any part of the
picture the full picture they may never
know and that's okay
but having any sort of inkling that
there's a picture
what happens is he gets out or they
visit him or they take a phone call with
him and he can paint a pretty clear
picture that mom's crazy
and your mom did this and suddenly
in a distorted puzzle all of their
confusion and frustration and absorption
of all that tension that they've
experienced over the years they get a
picture for it
and the puzzle pieces lock into place
and he suddenly is able to drive the
narrative see what I'm saying
I do I feel like that has happened
their whole lives it has you know he had
no problem you know telling them you
know Mommy doesn't want Daddy living at
home anymore
to you know I I have never been able to
say one one negative thing about their
dad right so here's what we're gonna do
this is not a conversation for you to
have by yourself you've got to get a
counselor
a trained counselor
especially with the 14 and 13 year old
and probably a play therapist with the
seven-year-old that that's kind of on
the border it will depend on the uh
maturity and wisdom of your
seven-year-old
um in fact I'm thinking about my kids I
would go One Direction with one in
another Direction with the other
but you are going to have a counselor
walk you and your child individually
through
um this conversation
and the reason we're gonna have a
counselor number one is we have what we
have to do is do something called
I'm trying to think of uh Layman we
gotta create safety we have to teach
these kids how to self-regulate when
they hear their everything they know
about their world is upside down
yeah and so there's going to be somebody
that teaches both of you and they're
going to watch you breathing exercises
writing journaling drawing pictures
thinking of things
you know uh
going for walks catching your breath all
these things in a like a seeking safety
protocol so that we can get to
the reason Daddy's in jail his daddy
hurt mommy really really bad for a long
time
and then that kid is going to hear that
from a counselor and is going to look
directly at you
and then that kid is going to feel shame
that they didn't see it they're going to
feel ashamed that they didn't stop it
they're going to feel all sorts of shame
that part of them is their dad and how
could I do that right all that stuff
that stuff's gonna happen and having
them have an already established
relationship with a professional
therapist is critical
okay
you don't do this one on your own a
especially not now
if you just took one of your kids out to
McDonald's and said hey I've got some
stuff some hard stuff I got to tell you
you are going to make them have to I
mean you're gonna so distort their world
they're gonna have to run to what's safe
and what's comfortable and
um they're gonna be ripe to be filled in
with stories either way
dad's evil mom's crazy back and forth
and back and forth
I want to go to the counselor I'm gonna
slow play this and slow play this and
say it in a way and then at some point
they'll bring the whole family in
because you'll have the what do we do
now conversation
and by the way
these records down the road
might be what's used in a parole hearing
or in a custody hearing
okay
okay so that when you tell that that 14
year old who's now 15 or 16
I'm not when you're 18 you can do what
you want to do your daddy is not safe
and so I am making the choice to keep my
kids safe and I understand that you miss
your dad I miss him too
but I'm safe now
see what I'm saying
yes I do it's a it's a tough messy thing
but can I ask you one hard question
underneath all of this
yeah
well I won't ask that question I'll ask
it in a different way
um
let me make a statement instead of
asking you a question I'll put you on
the spot that's kind of a mean question
I was going to ask
the greatest gift you can give those
kids
is you believing
that you are worth being well too and
you do not believe that
true or false
um
true
I feel like the energy that I can muster
up I I owe it to my kids to make sure
that they're okay
don't feel like I have time for both
at some point
because you choose to not take care of
you
they lose their mom
don't let that happen
you've heard this said a thousand times
in a thousand different places
when the plane goes into distress you've
got to put your oxygen mask on first
so that you can make sure every one of
those kids gets their oxygen mask on
but if you instantly start grabbing for
three kids who are a mess trying to get
their masks on and they're fighting you
and yelling you and taking them off when
you get them on pretty soon you pass out
and you're getting real close to your
Edge right
I am yeah
I know that because the his parole date
his get out date is getting closer
and
you can't think of that day even
your body still goes into
[Music]
pure survival it goes back to Hell into
those hard evil moments
gotta make a call today
foreign Emily
and I I want you to do this for you but
if if doing it for your kids helps you
make that first phone call and go to
that first and and the first one will be
easier than the second one second the
second counseling session will be
brutal the third one maybe even more so
I went to add a two-hour session the
other day and it was rough
but I'm telling you on the other side of
this
is a Clarity an ability to sleep
an ability to sit down across from an
attorney
and not have your body go to fight or
flight but to be able to say no no I
don't think you understand this is how
this is going to go
it's a world that you haven't
experienced in so long because you were
married to a person who hurt you all the
time
foreign
Emily
and when I say that I don't want you to
think of that as an extra chore when I
say I want you to take care of my friend
Emily that means I want you to go sit at
the feet of a professional and say
I'm ready for healing I'm ready to get
help I'm ready for
this pain to stop so that I can love
those kids
so that I can love those kids
I want you to hang on the line I'm gonna
send you a copy of on your past change
your future just for you you may have
already read it and if you haven't
um it's it's worth reading
um
there is no mistaking this you got a
tough road to hoe I mean it's going to
be a long journey forward
ask around get a couple of friends get a
couple people at your local church if
you go to church find some folks who
have a counselor that they trust and
reach out to that person
and your counselor should be able to
refer you to some childhood counselors
in the area so that they can help
facilitate these conversations there are
people who are specifically trained to
have these hard conversations with kids
it's both delicate and very direct and
it's uh it's a process
please keep me up to date let me know
how things are going and call anytime
and I'll walk alongside you Emily every
single step of the way
um
normally this is the part of the show
where we wrap up with song lyrics
um
uh
doesn't feel right today
and I know some of you have written to
us and said hey you can't do that to me
wait like you leave it hanging I need to
wrap the show up and I get that and I I
honor that
um if you have a song that means
something to you I want to challenge you
to take a moment before you take your
headphones out or get out of the car and
just sit for a moment
and hold it listen to that song that
means something to you
and I want to be real honest for a
second
um
hold your kids tight
hold your loved ones real tight
if you think you've got some big
solution and some big answer keep it to
yourself for a minute people are hurting
right now
arguing and bickering in fights and
complaints and well they should just
that will all come it will all come but
right now people are hurting
and most of us are so desperate to
escape that pain the reality of that
pain that we race off with our Solutions
and our answers and our finger pointing
and our yelling and screaming you should
just look at my Instagram it's
unbelievable what people are writing on
social media last night
and all of it all of it
is an effort to Stave off how bad this
hurts
that some evil
evil sick person
woke up one morning with the intent I'm
Gonna Hurt kids
Evelyn Haley William Cynthia Kathy Mike
we're gonna miss you with all of our
hearts
hold your loved ones tight goes real
real quick
this has been the Dr John Williams Show
foreign